bootleg cat backstage with my bro YG fo
hunted house this uh 2014 forest hill
drive toward been treating you my G
who's live um I said it's lit its lit is
going up it's good i noticed um you're
you're you're in good spirit sure you're
walking around just fine you you know
I'm saying you feeling good oh you
mooning group the new single is crazy
twist my fingers we talked on the phone
you told me that the new album is better
than the first album I said it's gonna
be blue and I nowhere near does who I
don't want to get into all of me you
focusing twist my fingers right now it's
growing up on the west coast I need
y'all to turn up it is a very like it's
like it might be the most west coast
song of all time you specify you from
this little generation or okay it also
see how [__] up are you right now I
know your voice is kind of you you were
drinking last night you're smoking but
how late are we in tampa tonight I'm
living a little I lose one of you got a
little bit petron I'm sober is you not
as a to sober gotta handle fireball in
here that until man could you lie eyes
be ready face be red because you like
light people and white and I get red you
saying like yeah y'all get faded into me
every deal with you got no rest bus he's
the homie sober yeah we were talking um
obviously a straight out of Compton came
out did you have a chance to go see it
yet Gina homies want to check it out
before your socks on it I love you we
was up my man when the other when he
went off yeah I'm like damn I'm on yall
already the humble like Italy been here
for two hours at a loss movie hey why
why no YG on the Compton album you are
and you we just talked about is going to
go you are the guy who made it out of LA
with no Draco sign should I ain't got
nothing to do it too nwe or the acid man
but it's Compton you are no bomb was
still his business though you friend me
so you how I'm as far as the album are
you gonna go I think what a lot of
people loved about my crazy life was it
was like like all the skits everything
tidy and it was like the concept really
it was like a story that played out
throughout the whole album is that
something that you
kind of continue with the new joint I'm
gonna make the music first make the
music first worry because because my
crazy life was like a day it was like a
day and a life type like before the
music you feel me before like the
success and all that [__] that's what my
crazy life was anything no more that
familiar though he did so I got to make
them you got new she to talk about yeah
what's the craziest groupie situation
you found yourself in YG you've been
known to keep a couple bad [__]
around what is like the craziest weather
it's like some obsessed fan that you had
to like she stepped out of line cuz she
had a cell phone I always told i was
returning home when somebody asked me
this question I'm I hi I'm gonna have
some phone off like you guys the I'm
trying thing because we haven't seen you
on bother alert you ain't been on the
TMZ men cologne plated
you see a crazy fan situation somebody
stepped out of pocket I need some help
you know this guy might know there's
over all crazy like I way ugc don't
manage it you only option is this crazy
like like a oh i can't come on that's
why portlet know your mother I'm a Rolex
watch you already done said it tell us
tell us a story no man I can't put that
on you already said it come on give it
give me the exclusive cain't me so what
happened with the Rolex mean attorneys
to did a chick try to take your Rolex
and I like that look me o ye but ain't
no Fame bet no crazy fan store yup those
tell us about this crazy story oh my
gosh you turn that thing on his head
yeah what happened to that new york in
new york and uh we uh we go out to the
little greenhouse club doesn't agree on
shows Bobby I am get the club we leavin
huffing the core car service we ride
around so I can get food is like four in
the morning and uh we stop by the liquor
store and see so we in like the hood is
soon I got his big eyes changing and
none of the homies got no straps so i'ma
leave my chain in the car even caught i
bounce oh I'm besos BAM I put my chain
up in the Louvre you know how to see
this a little dog [__] slam I big YZ
piece up in the air BAM we go to the
stove BAM hi back in the car driver
jumps on at the hotel hey I go to sleep
we leaving in the morning Pam I wake up
I'm like chain not one Finn I'm feeling
let my own accord me so I called homies
telling them they call it a driver and
all it dejar like nah man i got no tell
ya did you get you didn't get banging
that we go what's in your bag
go he's gone haha say like that straight
like that we look man the singles crazy
when we gonna get the video Oh video
coming soon have you had you got the
concept together you know me all right
on it's gonna be crazy he almost any
other movie coming out the movie was
fire you know it's doing numbers on
netflix all right on you work on a new
movies what I'm saying I'm white man
you're writing writing right now that's
what's up mmm I do yg the new album will
be out before the end of the year
hopefully um while you doing handsome
hopefully I'm saying it about the album
cuz we got single that don't matter me
UK you can't bring that who's your
favorite new besides these guys in your
cliq there's like a lot of dudes suture
guna ok I'm someone new cats at la a bit
stable oh you know I know who have you
seem to RJ's hard I know that's my dude
it's like you already know all the
people we already knew Jimmy rough
soldiers wouldn't know I ain't tryin to
see Nana was going about their we done
man I see